We
spend a lot of time talking about the
left around here,
but this week we're going to be diving
into the right.
My guest is conservative radio talk show
host,
lawyer and writer Larry Elder.
Larry has written several books on
conservative principles with a focus on
government and racial issues.
Much of his work is very similar
actually to the ideas we talk about here
on the Rubin report,
including religion,
the role of government and personal
responsibility.
According to his biography,
Larry uses facts and common sense to
arrive at his conclusions.
That sounds familiar right now.
If I use those same precepts as a
liberal,
can we both be right at the same time?
Can both be wrong?
Is the answer somewhere in the middle?
Well,
that's exactly what we're going to try
to find out.
As I discussed with Don Lemon last week,
the media talks so much about the left
right divide in this country that it's
easy to forget that there are decent
people on both sides of the debate.
This is one of the reasons I've taken
the left to task so much on this show.
The further off the deep end they go,
the less we'll be able to find
compromise with people we disagree with.
Just because I may have different views
on abortion than Republicans,
doesn't mean that they hate all women.
Just because I may have different views
than Republicans on guns doesn't mean
that there are a bunch of rednecks and
just because Republicans aren't for
legalizing marijuana doesn't mean they
aren't fun to hang out with.
All right,
well that one might be true,
but I think you see my point.
Maybe the best way to start a
conversation about political ideology is
to actually define the terms.
This is something I've done with a few
guests so far because I often think
we're all talking about different things
while using the same words.
Fear not.
I have Google and according to the
Oxford Dictionary,
here's the definition of conservatism.
Conservatism is the holding of
conservative principles.
The tendency to resist great or sudden
change,
especially in politics,
adherence to traditional values and
ideas sometimes opposed to liberalism.
Alright,
so I think we have a nice jumping off
point there.
Basically,
conservatives aren't big on change and
when they are,
they want to go about it slowly.
I think this concept has been conflated
with the concept of right wing politics,
so I even googled that.
According to the concise Oxford
Dictionary of politics in liberal
democracies,
the political right opposes socialism
and social democracy,
right wing parties include
conservatives,
Christian Democrats,
classic liberals,
nationalists,
and the far right racists and fascist.
You can see how these two concepts have
morphed into the Republican Party.
In America,
we have an ideology that doesn't want to
change the system to quickly coupled
with a political affiliation that is
focused on economics and some level of
moral authority.
Interestingly,
classical liberals are also included in
that group and the more and more I've
been talking about this stuff,
the more I've been considering myself in
that category.
I'm going to touch on that more in the
next couple of weeks.
Now that we've laid out some basic
terms,
I think we have a solid jumping off
point to discuss all the issues of the
day from abortion to economics,
to foreign policy to guns.
Can we find out where we agree instead
of just yelling over each other?
I think we can,
but the only way is to be brave enough
to talk to those we don't actually agree
with.
If we refuse to talk to those that we
don't see eye to eye with,
we'll just end up taking an eye for an
eye.
My guest this week is a lawyer,
a writer,
and host of the aptly named Larry Elder
radio show.
Larry,
has it gone on a great day.
Thank you for having me.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
Thanks for coming in.
I've been trying to make this happen
with you for awhile.
Dodge darts and you forever caught up
with me.
I.
I gotcha.
You've been in this studio before.
I have a guest hosted for Larry a couple
times.
Larry King or a king that's.
That's a Larry Man.
He has a thing and it's kind of for the
full hour.
Yeah,
he can.
He can only have people with the name.
Larry,
I guess those words.
So that worked out for you.
So there's a lot of stuff I want to talk
about it and in,
in the beginning of the show I set up
that I am a liberal or conservative
condolence.
This time this show is over,
we can move you to the center a little
bit and maybe by the time the show's
over weekend,
it's not gonna that's not at that,
but that's what it's all about.
That's why I've wanted to have you on
the show because I find there are some
people in the public space that I
disagree with,
but that I'd like to sit down and talk
about some of the ideas and I consider
you in that,
in that case.
Um,
but before we get to the politics,
I liked the audience,
know a little bit about the history of
the people I'm talking about.
So can you just,
I know you were born in La,
give me a little larry elder history.
Born and raised in La.
My Dad was a janitor.
He cleaned toilets.
Uh,
uh,
my dad was born in Athens,
Georgia.
Doesn't know who his mother,
his father,
his rather,
um,
uh,
my name's elder was a name with some
dude who's in his life the longest.
Uh,
my father was kicked out of his house
and was 13 years old by his
irresponsible grandmother and was on his
own from that point on,
on my mom.
Grew up on a farm kind of aristocracy
for,
for a black woman.
She,
uh,
owned the farm.
They owned the farm.
Anyway,
my dad and my mom got together and moved
to California in the forties.
I have two brothers.
Uh,
I am,
as you mentioned,
a lawyer,
uh,
born and raised in La and went to
college in the East Coast Law School in
the Midwest,
state in Ohio for about 17 years.
Came back to la about 22 years ago.
Got Into TV and radio and I've been
doing it ever since.
There you go.
All right.
So now we got.
We got the meat of what do you do that
you're not a practicing lawyer,
right?
Negative.
No,
I did it for two and a half,
three years and that was it.
I find a lot of people in the public
space either were lawyers at one time or
I know there's a ton of comedians that
were lawyers.
What is it about lawyers?
A lot of them want to get out.
What's that about?
I'm not sure that's true.
Um,
is just a real flexible thing to do.
You learn how to reason.
You learn about the law.
You learned about the constitution.
If you're a trial lawyer,
you learn how to think on your feet and
it lends itself to doing other things.
But most people I know who went to law
school,
at least the ones I went to law school
with a state and the law.
Yeah.
So was that a perfect segue to get you
to be someone that talks for a living?
Like instead of having to
litigate it in the courtroom,
you could litigate it on air and bounce
back and forth with people.
And that's right.
Although most lawyers are not trial
lawyers.
It's kind of the image of most lawyers
is that their Glib and fast.
Most lawyers sit behind a desk and fill
out papers.
There are tax lawyers or,
or constitutional lawyers or contract
lawyers or something like that.
Only about 10 percent of lawyers,
uh,
ended up going to becoming litigated.
And even a smaller number of those
actually try cases.
Yeah.
Alright.
So now let's talk about conservatism.
Let's do it.
So I've mostly been calling out the left
on my show because I consider myself
part of the left and I've seen the left
sort of really go off the deep end to
the left and I haven't been happy about
it.
So I haven't talked that much about the
right.
I've had a couple of people on the
So first off,
uh,
how would you define conservatism?
What do you think that even means at
this point in America in 2016?
What is it considered?
Well,
I don't mind being called a conservative
maturity.
I don't pretend to be a four letter
word,
but I really call myself a libertarian
a,
I believe in article one,
section eight of the constitution,
which gives the federal government a
small number of things to do.
Dave meant money.
Uh,
put together an army.
I'm a deal with the border is a handful
of other things.
That's it.
A welfare,
uh,
health care,
abortion,
same sex marriage,
Dr Sisto,
suicide,
all the social issues that the supreme
court takes up in my view,
they shouldn't take up in the first
place.
That should be done on a state by state
basis.
That's what I think most conservatives
believe as well.
So I'm with you on a lot and I
definitely have some libertarian beliefs
myself.
I think most people are libertarian.
They just don't know it.
The founding fathers were Libertarians,
the founding fathers drafted a document
that said our rights come from a power
other than individuals and government
doesn't give us our rights.
We give government our rights and power
and everything else should be left to
the states and to individuals.
So that's how the constitution would
start it.
That's how the country was started.
And I think that's how most Americans
really feel,
uh,
when they really think about it.
Well,
that's one of the funny things to me and
why I've defended somebody like rand
Paul,
who's a lot of people would say as a
liberal,
I shouldn't be defending,
he's libertarian,
but he's a libertarian,
so on issues such as a legalizing
marijuana or gay marriage,
a libertarian because you don't want the
government in your bedroom,
you shouldn't care about these issues.
And as a liberal,
I want people to do what they want and
marry who they want.
So that's somewhere where a libertarian
and the liberal can really sort of
joined together,
right?
I think so.
However you have people like Bill Maher
running around calling himself a
libertarian.
Bill Maher is not a libertarian.
He believes in higher taxes.
He believes in a minimum wage.
He supported a Ralph Nader for,
for government who wants to take over
businesses and have government run them.
Uh,
so a lot of people use it because it's
the sexy kind of term and have no idea
what it is.
Right?
So that's the economic side of it.
So you,
you're sort of,
he's liberal on the social stuff and in,
in a way as a conservative,
you're,
you're actually pretty liberal on the
concern on the social stuff.
Again,
I believe that same sex marriage,
doctor assisted suicide,
all these kinds of things,
abortion should be done on a state by
state basis in California.
We had to,
uh,
um,
opportunities to vote for or against a
same sex marriage,
a proposition 30 and another time when
we voted on,
I think it was called,
um,
uh,
issue eight,
measure eight.
And in both cases I voted in favor of
same sex marriage in both cases I was
overruled.
I have no problem with the idea that the
majority of my fellow Americans,
uh,
or our fellow Californians did not agree
with me.
I don't believe that I then go to the
Supreme Court and cram it down their
throats of the other states.
Right.
Okay.
So then that's,
that's the state's rights issue and sort
of.
So you would say that the Supreme Court
is legislating from the bench or
something to that effect?
Yeah,
I wouldn't.
Yeah.
And that,
so,
so you're basically okay with what
happened,
you just don't like how it had.
Correct.
Yeah.
So someone like Rand Paul,
uh,
because it sounds like you have a lot.
Do we are supporting?
Not,
no,
I'm not.
No,
I don't.
I don't,
I don't like Rand Paul because of his
position on foreign affairs and defense.
A lot of libertarians and I don't think
being a libertarian leads you to being
an isolationist,
although most libertarians are for
reasons that I think are kind of
confusing,
but a rand Paul is one of those guys who
attacked George W Bush for the Iraq war.
I think we were justified in going
there.
I think that the reason for going there
were legitimate and I think a lot of
liberals are hypocritical on this issue
to.
You talked about how you,
you chastise people on the left for
being hypocrites.
I'll give you one big one.
The argument against the Iraq war is
that George W dot Bush foolishly wanted
to impose our values on another,
uh,
another culture,
had no idea what the aftermath would be
if we get rid of this bad guy.
Right.
However,
Obama comes into office,
he joined with the British and the
French in bombing Libya.
Getting rid of Qaddafi.
Why W he threatened us?
No,
they did.
So for humanitarian,
uh,
civil rights reasons read recently at a
debate was asked about why she did that.
She said,
well,
uh,
so they can have free elections.
Where was the left?
Same thing with regard to,
to Egypt.
We get rid of Mubarak.
He was a thug,
but they're all thugs.
The Muslim Brotherhood comes in there,
uh,
and Obama backs them,
um,
and,
and the country is worse than it was
before.
And then a.now
backing the guy that took over after the
genocide for reasons that escape me,
Obama decided,
saw it had to go.
Yeah.
Why these,
these countries did not threaten us.
The way,
in my opinion,
erected a Irak was a deal after the,
after nine slash 11,
90 percent of the American people
believe that we're going to get hit
again.
Uh,
and this guy was stealing from the oil
for food program.
He was,
uh,
he was,
interfering with our patrolling the
southern didn't no fly zones.
Uh,
he had used chemical weapons on his own
people we know that because it used them
on the Iranians.
They used them on the Kurds.
Uh,
he tried to assassinate George Herbert
Walker Bush.
Uh,
he was a threat,
uh,
and like it or not,
at least we had a legitimate reason for
going there.
And he got the backing of both the house
and the Senate.
Obama did,
did,
did Egypt,
and he did Libya and he did a,
uh,
Syria without the backing of Congress.
And yet the left didn't say a damn
thing.
Right.
So,
yeah.
So I'm,
I'm with you on the hypocrite part
because I listen,
I was,
there's plenty of video.
I was against the Libya thing because at
the very least,
at the very,
very least,
if we're going to have a military
action,
we should have congressional approval.
Right?
So then the,
instead of calling it a war,
they called it a kinetic military
action.
And beyond that,
uh,
Libya did not pose a threat to us.
He had no WMD because he gave them up
after we went into the war in Iraq.
He was scared.
Belief plus he gave up the WMD and not
the United Nations.
He gave it to us if they're under lock
and key,
uh,
in Tennessee as we speak.
So what was the rationale and where was
the left?
The same people yelling and screaming
about George W dot Bush and Dick Cheney
and neo-cons and,
and nation building.
Where were they?
They didn't say anything.
It's hypocritical.
Yeah.
Well,
listen,
we don't have congressional
authorization right now.
So I would assume by a lot of standards
on the left,
Obama is probably a gun to them,
right?
If they,
if they're being consistent but they're
not.
So.
But what was the actual threat?
I mean,
so I'm with you on some of this in terms
of that we all sort of pick our sides
and then our.
Our value suddenly changed depending on
who's in power,
but what,
what do you think your principals you,
you don't do that and I'd write it
myself to be a principal.
I,
I consider myself to be principled as
well,
so I.
everything that I've said in the past
related to all this stuff still still
stands up,
but what was the actual threat from
Iraq?
Look,
I know that that Saddam did horrible
things and you've laid out a couple of
them,
but what?
What was the actual threat?
And George W dot Bush properly said that
they were a grave and gathering danger
after nine slash 11.
Ninety percent of the American people
thought we were going to get hit again
and thought that he was going to be
bigger than nine slash 11.
So George W Bush looks around and says,
where are the threats?
We were still technically at war against
it.
I was saying we went to war against him
in 1991 and he promised to fully and
thoroughly declare his,
his chemical and biological weapons he
failed to do so he violated resolution
after resolution after resolution,
and we feared that he would either use
them himself or give them to a terrorist
and use them against us and make 9:11,
looked like a picnic.
That was a threat.
We gave him 15 months to turn over this
stuff and he refused to do it.
Uh,
a Bush went to the ninth and it did turn
out that there were no nuclear weapons
of mass destruction.
Actually,
I disagree with that as well.
I believe the weapons were there.
We gave him 15 months to thoroughly
declare what he did in that 15 months.
In my opinion,
he got rid of it.
And I'm not the only person that's said
that.
Dave the,
um,
the national intelligence director,
our top spy,
his name is James Clapper.
He's an office right now under Obama,
has publicly said he believes that
Saddam Hussein did in fact have
stockpile for WMD,
got rid of them in the,
during the 15 month run up to the war.
The,
uh,
Israeli Mossad feels the same way.
And there's several other American
officials that have said that.
So I don't believe George W Bush got the
intelligence wrong.
We have 16 intelligence agencies.
All 16 said at the highest level of
probability that Saddam Hussein had
stockpiles of chemical and biological
weapons.
Obama had the same CIA director who
served under Bill Clinton,
George Tenant.
He said the likelihood that Saddam
Hussein had chemical weapons and
biological weapons was a slam dunk.
And the same people that call up George
W Bush a moron when he wanted him to go.
So all 16 of you guys say that he's this
stuff and you say you've got to George.
I just not feeling it,
so I'm not going to do it,
but he's a moron.
So would you say that this is one of the
cases that part of the problem,
and I think this is a through line
through everything we're going to
discuss for the next hour,
is that I don't know who to believe
anymore.
That's become a thing.
So James Clapper,
who you just mentioned,
he's the same guy,
the same CIA director who sat in front
of Congress and said that we're not
spying on Americans remember,
and he was scratching the top of his
head because as they say in Seinfeld,
when you're lying,
you touch the higher up you touch on
your face and the bigger the lie is,
and he's great.
And he says,
we're not wittingly spying on the
American public.
We now know that that wasn't what he
said was,
I gave the least untruthful answer I
could give,
but later on he admitted it.
And so to me,
as far as I'm concerned,
he's.
He's legitimately honest guy.
Well I guess he gave the least honest
answer.
He least untruthful and least
untruthful.
But it wasn't I guess I guess.
But it wasn't truthful.
Well,
it was classified.
It was classified.
He wasn't supposed to talk about it,
but.
All right,
so without,
without getting too caught up in the
words though,
but do you think that's part of the
problem that we just don't know who to
believe anymore?
I don't believe our government
officials.
We barely believe the media.
Well,
I have my own issues with government,
but my thing,
my problem with the Iraq war is that
Republicans failed to say what I've said
and defended.
Even Jeb Bush is not defended that
properly.
He was asked when he first started
running.
What do you think about the rack?
Wah,
Wah.
But I,
I mean,
honestly,
if you can't even defend what your
brother did,
how can other people do it?
So I think Americans have forgotten why
we went there at one time,
73 percent of the American people's
support at this war.
You have to remind people of why you've,
why you've gone to war and remind people
what the reasons are and people have
forgotten it.
Now they have this vague idea that
George w Bush overreacted and,
and went in there and depose somebody
because he just didn't like him.
Uh,
and uh,
that's why we were there and let's not
do that anymore.
That's kind of how people have given the
cliff notes version of what happened and
it's unfair.
So what would you say to the people that
would argue that isis wouldn't exist
right now if we hadn't toppled sit down
because he at least had for all the
horrible things he was doing in the bath
party.
We're doing terrible things and they
were executing people and throwing gays
off roofs and uh,
you know,
using mustard gas on the courage and all
that stuff,
but at least he was keeping a sort of
lid on the actual craziness that we're
seeing right now.
Um,
my,
my problem with that is that we don't
know what Saddam Hussein would have done
had we not gone there,
even though we didn't find the
stockpiles.
There were two people that George W Bush
sent to find the stockpiles.
One was named David k,
the other was named chuck doll for both
of them said we didn't find any
stockpiles.
We screwed up.
However,
this guy was going to reconstitute his
WMD program and reconstitute his nuclear
program.
When the heat was off,
so we would have had a dope deal with
him.
Anyway.
The second thing I say is that President
Obama pulled out all the truth because
he ran in 2008 and said the Iraq war was
a dumb war.
We never should've gone there.
Over the advice of Hillary as secretary
of state over the advice of his
secretary of defense,
Leon Panetta,
over the advice of his former secretary
of defense,
Robert Gates,
over the advice of the joint chiefs.
He pulled out all the troops.
He was warned,
if you do this,
there'll be a vacuum.
He did it.
Anyway.
Ray Odierno is a member of the joint
chiefs.
He just retired and he gave a speech
when he retired and he was asked if he.
Does he believe that we should have left
people there?
He says,
yes.
Have we done so?
I said,
it could have been dealt with,
so in my opinion,
however you feel about it,
when Obama walked in,
inherited this mess,
he should have made it better and not
worse.
He made it worse.
So in a way you're,
so you're sort of blaming both sides,
right in that,
in that,
or I guess I would blame both sides.
I want put words in your mouth.
I would blame both sides here and that
we went to the wrong war and then by
Obama leaving the way he did,
even though most of the Americans very
clearly didn't want to be there anymore
and when he ran for president seven
years ago that his whole thing was,
we're going to get out as soon as
possible,
but that then created the breeding
ground for this because we didn't leave
in a in a sorta.
I'll go halfway with you.
We didn't go into the wrong war.
Went to the right war for the right
reasons.
I think the intelligence was good and I
think the problem was when Obama came
in,
he wanted to get out so quickly that he
did not realize what the aftermath would
be.
And I'm not the only one who said this.
Robert has written a book scathing
attack,
the most scathing attack on a sitting
commander in chief by a former member of
cabinet member I've ever read,
and he even recently,
just a few days ago,
Dave said that Obama's national security
and foreign policy advisors are
dangerously naive.
They see the world through this prism
that they want,
which is why the Benghazi thing
happened.
The reason that mid godly thing happened
as Obama's running in 2012 a GM is dead.
A GM is alive.
Osama bin Laden is dead and Qaeda is on
the run.
Therefore,
Ben Gazi was not thoroughly defendant
because they thought that the Libyans
were happy with us because we got rid of
Gaddafi.
Yeah.
Uh,
and so,
at least in my opinion,
the Obama Administration sees the world
through their prism of this ridiculous
idea that if we are nicer to people and
reach out with an unclenched fists,
they will reach out in kind.
The world doesn't work that way.
We have bad people who hate us and we
need to deal with it.
Right?
So I'm with you on that part for sure.
Because look,
if you think back to the big speech that
Obama gave in Cairo,
which was the,
everyone said,
this is the reset,
this is the,
we're going to be different.
We're going to try to deal with people
in region less with more with
discussion.
I mean the Middle East especially,
but most of the world we were in more of
a precarious place now than I don't
think any part of the world is better
off with Obama in a.
and I think that you look at polls now,
George W Bush left office,
uh,
in the,
in the low thirties.
I don't think any president has been
that unpopular in my lifetime.
You look at polls now,
more people like George W Bush didn't
like Obama.
Obama's rating is at 45 percent.
Bill Clinton's at this juncture in the
seventh year of his term,
he was at 65 percent.
Most American believer on the wrong
track economically.
And most Americans believe we're on the
wrong track in terms of foreign policy.
Yeah.
Alright.
So I don't want to get too lost in,
in just foreign policy.
So last thing on this is a lot of what
you're saying sort of sounds like
neoconservative stuff to me is there,
can you be a libertarian and a
neoconservative?
I mean,
I know this is what you're getting to
before.
This is sort of why you don't like Ran
Paul,
but do those things seemed like they
have nothing to do with each other and
yet I know that there's a lot of people
that do sort of get what you're,
what you're saying.
Well,
the term neoconservatives and to me as a
four letter word is a term that people
invent to,
to malign somebodies position.
I see the world realistically.
I think we have enemies.
We need to deal with them.
Uh,
I did not believe,
as you did just now pointed out that we
should have gone to war in,
in Libya.
I don't believe in doing anything unless
it's consistent with our national
security interests.
When Jimmy Carter,
for example,
uh,
through the Shah of Iran under the bus
in the seventies,
what was that all about?
He did it because he wanted freedom.
He wanted to liberate the people who are
behind bars,
the same people we now call terrorists.
Uh,
these are the ones that Obama force the
shaw to let out of prison and they
ultimately topple the regime.
What's that all about?
It's not our job to impose democracy.
It's our job to make sure that countries
are not our enemies.
Our countries are doing things that are
consistent with our own national
security interest.
That,
that's my problem.
Right?
So you don't want to nation build,
you want to do things that you consider
sort of defensive posture.
Correct.
We went into a,
a,
a Haiti I think during Bill Clinton's
administration because they were having
difficulties,
not our job.
Uh,
I want to get this right.
So I'm gonna.
Look at my notes for this.
According to this,
uh,
you are black,
is that correct?
That is correct.
Not African American.
That's not a term I like you.
How come you don't like the term as
ridiculous?
I was born and raised in America.
I've never been to Africa.
Uh,
how,
why am I an African American?
Most of my people that have been here
longer than most of other other people
in this room,
uh,
yet most people don't have a hyphen.
Uh,
you know,
I'm an Italian American,
Greek American,
Romanian American.
It's an absurd term.
It's a term that Jesse Jackson almost
single handedly cram,
cram down the throats of our media.
And after Jackson began to talk about
why a black should have some connection
to Africa,
all of a sudden New York Times,
La Times,
all of the media began using that
expression.
It's the excellence.
Yeah.
I mean,
I personally don't use the term African
American that much because one time I
had a guest on the show and I referred
to her is African American.
She said,
well,
I'm actually Jamaican.
So,
you know what I mean.
So I guess that that goes to your point.
And I remember reading one time,
Dave,
somebody,
uh,
was given a description of some suspect
who had done some crime,
was running away,
uh,
and uh,
he was described as an African American.
How do you know where he was from?
Goodman from Africa coming from Jamaica,
from Canada.
So what are they going,
what,
what do you make of that when someone
like [inaudible] I know you really rail
against Jesse Jackson and,
and these guys on the left that use,
and I want to talk a lot about identity
politics.
So the guys that use these phrases,
what are they going for?
Their.
Well,
their goal,
the goal is to tell black people that
were victims that uh,
discrimination and racism remain major
problems in America when in fact they
don't,
uh,
and uh,
they want black people to vote for the
Democratic Party.
The Democratic Party gets a 95 percent
of the black vote.
Uh,
and the reason they get it is because
blacks are convinced that the number one
issue facing the country right now is
social justice,
racist,
white cops,
uh,
discrimination,
systemic racism,
microaggression,
whatever,
a new word that come up with and as a
bunch of nonsense.
And number one problem domestically
facing this country is a breakdown of
the family.
And uh,
President Obama said it,
I didn't have a black kid or kid,
not just the black kid.
A kid raised without a dad is five times
more likely to be poor and commit crimes
nine times more likely to drop out of
school and 20 times more likely to end
up in jail.
So you're far more likely to end up in
jail without having a dad than you are
because of a white racist cop.
Right?
So,
but you wouldn't not acknowledge that
there are some systemic issues.
And give me an example.
Tell me what you think the most
instamatic racist issue is.
What is it?
Well,
I would say that because black people in
most cases,
in many cases we're descendants of
slaves.
That racism as a,
as an institution that in 2000 a certain
amount of it just exists.
Two thousand and 15.
That gives me the most blatant racist
example you can come up with right now.
Um,
I think you could probably find evidence
that in general cops or the cops are
more willing to shoot if the perpetrator
is black.
What's your date of Nyu?
What's your basis for saying that last
year will look.
I know a lot of people would say,
look what's going on.
And I know what they would say,
I'm talking about what the facts are.
Nine hundred and 65 people were shot by
cops last last year and killed four
percent of them were white cops shooting
unarmed blacks in,
in Chicago in 2011,
21.
People were shot and killed by cops.
Uh,
in 2015 there were seven a in Chicago,
which is a third black,
a third white,
and a third Hispanic.
Seventy percent of the homicides are
black on black,
uh,
about 40 per month,
almost 500 in the per year last year in
Chicago.
And 75 percent of them are unsolved.
Whereas the black lives matter on that,
the idea that a racist white cop
shooting unarmed black people is apparel
to black people is bs,
is complete and total bs.
And,
and the reason for these so-called
activists saying this is the assumption
that racism remains a major problem in
America.
The media,
CNN,
especially MSNBC runs down whenever a
black cop shoots somebody,
uh,
and,
and uh,
and it's,
uh,
some,
some march on Washington.
It's ridiculous.
A black people,
half the homicides in this country are
committed by and against black people.
Last year there were 14,000
homicides.
Not talking about suicide.
I'm talking about homicides.
Half of them were black.
90 six percent of them black on black.
Of that 7,000.
Where's the black on black lives matter.
People on that.
So there's where you would say that this
is purely because of social justice,
purely because they want ultimately for
people to be angry enough to just keep
voting democrat.
That's right.
And where's,
where's the evidence of a lack of social
justice when a black suspect is killed
by a cop?
Believe me,
the media's on it.
People are watching it.
Uh,
and uh,
and justice will,
will for the most part to occur in
Baltimore where Freddie gray was killed.
Freddie gray died in a van,
I shouldn't say was killed.
Died in a van.
Yeah.
You have a city that's a 45 percent.
Black City Council is 100 percent
Democrat.
The majority of city council is black.
The top cop at the time was with black.
The number two cop with black,
the majority of the command staff is
black,
the mayor is black,
the age is black.
Uh,
and yet here we are talking about
racism.
I mean,
it's,
it's absurd.
It's absurd.
So it's funny,
I find myself caught in between this a
little bit as a liberal where I want to
always try to defend the other.
So in this case,
the other being black people,
I'm always sympathetic to that.
And they,
uh,
yeah,
yeah.
At the same time I hear you laying out a
pretty solid.
Well,
these are just the facts.
I'll tell you something else too,
that was just a study,
a university of Washington,
uh,
and it turns out cops were more
reluctant,
more hesitant to pull the trigger
against the blacks black suspect than a
white suspect.
Uh,
probably because of the fear of being
accused of racially profiling and the
fear that the civil rights establish it
was going to come down on him.
So if anything,
uh,
whites are more likely to be shot by a
cop under,
under certain circumstances than a,
than a,
than a black person.
And in last 30 or 40 years,
the number of percentage of suspects
killed by cops who are black has
declined.
Seventy five percent.
However,
the percentage of whites killed by cops
has flatlined.
Yeah.
And so if anything,
people are more concerned about shooting
black people for fear that they're going
to be called racist.
And almost all every one of these
incidents,
whether it's Eric Gardener in in New
York who died because he was selling
loosies and we resisted arrest,
whether there's Tamir rice in Cleveland
who hit,
was twirling around the gun,
whether it's Michael Brown in Ferguson
who had just a committed and strong arm
robbery.
Almost every one of these incidents
involve somebody resisting arrest.
Why don't you just do what the police
tell you?
My Dad said,
when I get pulled over,
had my hand at 10:00,
have my hand at 2:00
say yes sir.
No Sir.
Make sure my paperwork is in order.
And if I feel the cop is mistreating me,
get a badge number and deal with it.
Later on.
If Jesse Jackson and Al Sharpton and
Obama and the whole group of them told
black people to do that,
we'd have a lot fewer of these things to
deal with in the first place.
Yeah.
All right.
So,
um,
with the,
uh,
I'm hearing a lot of what you're saying
in here.
So as a black conservative then who now
you've,
you've laid out your case there,
but you haven't laid out yours.
I asked,
I asked you to name the most important
example of racism and you gave white
cops going after black people and I,
and I told you,
gave you the facts for that.
So that's nonsense that you must have
something else.
What else does it,
if you think racism remains a problem in
America?
Give it to.
Well,
I think it remains a problem.
How do you not even tell me it may not
be systemic in that we have.
It's not like you're not being hired
because you're black.
There's no systemic reason,
you know,
legal reason that,
that exists,
that kind of thing.
But I think that racism as a general,
uh,
I need some.
I need some specifics that you gave me,
the white cop thing.
What else?
Give me another example.
What do you think is a problem?
We'll,
we'll,
uh,
as a black conservative telling me how
to know you,
how do you get people to come around?
You're,
you're the one who made the assertion
that racism remains a major problem in
America.
I asked you to give me an example.
You gave me white cops going after
blacks.
I,
as far as I'm concerned,
you didn't hold it up very well.
It was the other argument you have.
What's the other thing?
Well,
I don't know that it's systemic in that
in the sort of macro sense,
I'm not an ad.
I know that.
I want to know what it is you're,
you're talking.
No,
no,
that,
that's exactly what that's.
Believe me,
that's 100 percent.
You're not getting into school bs that
we have a race.
We have affirmative action.
So a black person with a,
with an sat and a GPA of x,
we'll,
we'll get into a school faster and
easier than a white person with an sat
or a gpa of x.
and if going to,
going to school is a route to the middle
class,
you can make an argument that blacks
have an easier route to middle to the
middle class.
If you're talking about a black poverty,
um,
the poorer you are,
the more accessible loans and grants are
for you.
Uh,
the,
the problem,
the biggest burden that black people
have in my opinion,
again,
is the percentage of blacks,
75 percent of them that are raised
without fathers,
uh,
and that has every other social negative
consequences connected to it.
Crime,
uh,
not being able to compete economically
in the country,
being more likely to be arrested.
That's the number one problem facing the
black community.
And when I hear people telling me about
systemic racism or unconscious racism,
I always say,
give me an example.
And almost nobody can do it.
So,
so the family stuff.
So I'll follow your logic there and
family stuff.
What can actually be done about that
then?
Because that's a big reverse.
The welfare state,
uh,
in 18,
90,
1900,
you look at census reports,
a black kid,
believe it or not,
with slightly more likely to be born to
a nuclear family than a white kid.
Even during slavery,
uh,
a black kid was more likely to be born
under a roof with his biological mother
and biological father.
Then today what's happened is we
launched this so called war on poverty
in the sixties were literally,
Lyndon Johnson sent,
people were knocking on doors and I
lived in the sixties and people knocked
on doors uprising.
Women of their availability to welfare
provided there was no man in the house.
And we went from 25 percent of black
being born outside of wedlock and 65 to
75 percent right now.
And you look at how much money that we
spent on welfare,
uh,
in the lines are parallel.
It was a neutron bomb dropped on this
country and not just in the black
community,
but on people in general.
Uh,
at one time,
only about five percent of whites were
born outside of wedlock.
Now 25 percent of whites are born
outside of wedlock.
I was in college in 1970 and there was a
report called the Moynihan report.
Uh,
the Negro family,
a case for national action is written by
liberal by a man who became a Democratic
senator for from New York.
And at the time 25 percent of black kids
are born outside of wedlock.
He said,
my God,
this number is,
is horrific.
If we don't do something about it,
it could get even higher.
Well,
fast forward 25 percent of white kids
and now born outside of wedlock.
It is the number one problem in this
country.
And what we've done in my opinion,
is we've economically incentivized women
to marry the government and we've
allowed men to abandoned their financial
and more responsibility.
And now we have this.
So do you think the left has done this?
Right?
Okay.
So do you think then that as a,
as a black conservative,
that the biggest issue is it's
impossible to have this conversation,
right?
Right.
Like the stuff we're talking about right
now is rarely discussed in the media.
You know,
people,
you've written some books about it and
people talk about it every now and
again,
but we rarely have this discussion
because,
and this is where I will agree with you
that the left has made language such a
problem and everyone's so trigger
warnings and safe space that we're
afraid that if you have this
conversation,
that somehow I'm going to come off
racist.
You know,
that's not where we were,
where we don't have the conversation.
We don't have the conversation because
the left within have to look in the
mirror and go,
Jesus h Christ,
look at what I've done and they don't
want to do this.
I've had a radio show for almost 25
years.
I've invited Jesse Jackson on 50 times
60 times.
I've invited our sharpened on that.
That number,
a maxine waters,
another loud mouth,
black woman around here with running
around talking about racism.
She won't come on my show either.
They don't want to deal with these
issues.
Why?
Let's have a conversation.
If I'm wrong,
tell me I'm wrong.
Tell me how I'm wrong.
Give me your data.
Give me your facts.
Tell me what you got,
and I could quote the,
the Brookings Institution,
which is a liberal think tank and the
Heritage Foundation,
which is a conservative think tank and
they will both tell you that there's a
relationship between crime and bad
schools,
uh,
and going to prison and not having a
dad.
So this is not just a liberal kind of
thing or conservative kind of thing.
It's a real world kind of thing and they
don't want to have that conversation.
I have never heard a reporter ask Obama
about the connection between the rise of
the single parent household and the rise
of,
of welfare spending.
I've never heard anybody ask him that
question.
Not one time.
Yeah.
And so as far as I'm concerned,
is this,
this,
um,
desire not to have this conversation for
fear that then will cause you to rethink
your assumptions.
A psychologist would call that cognitive
dissonance the,
the,
this,
this anxiety that you feel when you have
had your assumptions challenged and you
don't want to do it.
It's uncomfortable.
Yeah.
So how then would someone like you or
someone that believes in what the things
that you're talking about,
how do you wrestle away a little bit of
the narrative from the black lives
matter folks,
because obviously you tell them,
I tell the true care about the same
thing.
Of course I do.
I tell the truth.
I talk about,
uh,
the number one cause of preventable
death for young white men is car
accidents.
The number one cause of preventable
death for young black men is homicide
committed by other young black men.
I tell the truth,
I give the facts and the facts are
racist.
Yeah.
So facts or racist Hashtag facts are
racist,
right?
So,
uh,
you know,
I'm friends with,
uh,
another black conservative,
David Webb,
you probably know Sirius Xm and he's a
Fox News contributor and I had been
doing a progressive show awhile back and
I was on with someone and they didn't
know him personally,
nor knew that I was friends with him and
they kept saying he's the token black
guy on Fox right now.
I'm sure you get plenty of token boot
licker,
uncle Tom,
sambo,
sambo.
Tom Coconut as in Brown on the outside,
white on the inside,
a Oreo same concept,
a the antichrist,
and you've got a hold of because they've
got to maligned somebody like me.
I am a bigger threat to their whole
ideology than almost anybody else.
A black guy who does not believe that
he's a victim of black guy who believes
in hard work and personal
responsibility.
A black guy who doesn't believe in
handouts.
Black guy doesn't believe in the welfare
state of black guy.
He doesn't believe in affirmative
action.
I am the antithesis of everything they
stand for and therefore I can't just be
dealt with with facts and everybody with
X.
I've got to be maligned.
I've got to be a castaway.
I've got to be treated as as if I'm
darth vader.
That's what the left does.
So That's interesting.
And again,
this is where I've really struggled with
my guys on the left because in a way
that is actually showing it's race.
Of course it is.
That's right.
Because I don't have the same right to
have an opinion.
If somebody else.
I've never heard rush limbaugh be called
anti white because he criticizes hillary
and the Left,
but I criticize black left people and
I'm and I'm,
I'm anti-black.
It's bigotry.
It's racism.
Calling somebody.
An uncle Tom is as offensive.
It's calling somebody an inward lover.
Yeah.
So when it comes to,
to the black community and politics.
So I got you on a bunch of bunch of this
stuff.
The black community in a lot of ways
isn't for some of the things that the
Democratic Party is for,
right?
Because the black community a lot of
times,
and it has a lot to do with the church
is more socially conservative.
The only thing that that connects black
people to the Democratic Party in my
opinion,
is this notion of social justice and
this notion that racism remains a major
problem in America.
Look down the list of,
of things that black people like and
support.
Blacks are more pro life than whites
are.
Blacks were more anti gay marriage,
uh,
than,
than whites were.
That's one of the reasons its
proposition passed here in California is
because of the way blacks and browns
voted.
Again,
I didn't vote that way,
but it's the way a lot of blacks and
browns did.
Um,
uh,
blacks want to be wealthy.
One of the reason Donald Trump is
getting about 25 percent of black,
which is five times by the way,
the percentage that Mitt Romney got is
because of Donald Trump's swagger and
his,
um,
and his,
uh,
being proud that he's made money.
Uh,
and so and,
and in the inner city,
right?
That's a really fascinating little piece
right there because I never want one
more quick one.
This is important.
The Democratic Party is completely
beholden to the teacher's union and vice
versa.
Uh,
the union is adamantly opposed to
vouchers where the money follows the kid
rather than the other way around.
Inner city black women and fathers and
their inner city,
black,
Brown women and Brown fathers want
vouchers.
They realized the schools suck.
I went to crenshaw high school in south
central right now,
three percent.
That's not a typo.
Three percent of kids can do math at
grade level.
I'm going to send my kid to that school
because I don't have enough money to
send my kid to a better school.
It's,
it's,
it's an assault,
a.
there's a program called the DC hope
scholarship program where every year,
uh,
parents who subscribed to the,
to the program,
it's four times as many people wanting
to get in as there are seats,
will give a kids about 10 to $12,000
to go to a non a DC government school.
And every two years when it's over Obama
and the Democrats climate try to shut it
down.
And the reason they don't is a bunch of
black parents go to the streets,
have a press conference,
dark crying.
And so all my kids doing better.
I can't think of anything more damaging
to a kid's future,
is to send him to a school where it's a
crip school where the kids are,
are,
are not learning where a lot of them are
not learning because they don't care.
And where the whole level is now dumbed
down to cater to that lowest common
denominator in a class.
And as a result,
you have kids that have a poor sat
scores and they otherwise would,
if they had a chance to go somewhere
else that challenged them.
Um,
and so inner city parents want vouchers.
Young black people when they're told
about the benefits of privatizing social
security,
uh,
want to do it because 65 years old
blacks die sooner than whites do.
And when you die,
all your contribution to social security
go poof,
as opposed to being able to distill it
to your child.
When black duck taught about this,
young blacks want the opportunity to put
their money into an account that they
can control.
So when they get 65 years old,
they have real money.
So privatizing social security vouchers,
a abortion,
same sex marriage,
all of these issues,
black are really not in lockstep with
the Democratic Party,
but the Democratic Party has
successfully,
uh,
convinced blacks that racism,
this white cop,
this is widespread,
that man's out to get you and vote for
us and we'll deal with it.
So how much of this is a messaging?
Probably if I grant you all of that,
right?
How much of this is just a messaging
problem by the Republicans because it
seems to me,
and I've said this several times,
but someone like Tim Scott who is a
black Republican senator from the south,
right?
He should be a hero,
not only of the black community,
but he should really be a hero of the
left.
Right?
Because this is a successful black.
Could be an American hero.
He really should be.
I mean,
he should some,
certainly at least at the very least be
bigger in the national debate.
Why isn't he a bigger surrogate for
whoever he's going to support?
I assume it will be a republican.
Uh,
why is this guy lost in,
in the scheme of things?
Well,
it's the same reason that black vote 95
percent for the Democratic Party,
he is considered to be a,
an uncle Tom.
He's a Republican.
He's a black Republican,
a,
he's a,
he's some sort of Unicorn.
I don't know what he is,
that,
that's how,
that's how they feel.
So then what do you do?
What do you do as a Republican to break
this narrative?
You know,
I got it.
You told,
tell the truth.
I got it.
You tell the truth,
but obviously there has to be something
bigger than messaging here because.
Well,
it telling me the numbers.
90,
95,
it's an uphill fight.
I mean,
to me there is a access of
indoctrination and you have the media,
you have academia and you have
Hollywood,
uh,
all of which tell black people that
they're victims.
Um,
most professors are to the left.
the media certainly is off to the left
and holly was to the left.
And so you get up and you're
indoctrinated all the time with things
like social justice,
inequality,
uh,
the man's out to get you a,
we need a higher minimum wage.
You name the left wing,
uh,
a policy and,
and you,
and you pick it up through osmosis.
That's why when we first started the
conversation,
I said,
I hope to move you towards the center
and you say,
I hope to move you towards,
uh,
towards the,
towards the center.
And I said,
it's not going to happen because.
Because I'm there,
there's nothing you can tell me I
haven't heard.
But I probably can say some things your
audience hasn't heard a because La
Times,
New York Times,
CNN,
ABC,
NBC,
CBS,
New York Times,
uh,
you name it,
these are all to the left,
whatever,
left wing position,
uh,
you're going to hear it,
you're going to hear a why,
how and where,
but,
but the other position you won't hear
unless you watch a Fox News or listen to
talk radio and a lot of people won't do
it if you make them,
if you pay them.
Right.
So I hope it's clear in our 40 minutes
or so together so far when I say I'm on
the left,
I consider myself a classic liberal and
that I stand for liberal principles.
John Stuart mill type liberal.
Exactly,
exactly.
That's,
that's not a liberal.
And,
and I know in a lot of ways that that
makes you a conservative.
You're a Jack Kennedy,
kind of a kind of Democrat.
He cut taxes.
He was a cold warrior.
He will.
He liked hunting.
He liked the second amendment.
So it doesn't really show you how stupid
the words are.
So what I did at the top of the no shows
you how the Democratic Party has evolved
to the left and abandoned principles.
My mom was a,
was a Democrat,
my mom was a Republican,
my dad was a republican all his life and
my mom stopped voting for the Democratic
Party and she said,
as many people have said,
I didn't leave the Democratic Party.
They left me.
She didn't like welfare.
She didn't like the idea of rewarding
people just because you had a kid and
they'd given you more money when you had
an additional kids.
She didn't like any of all of that and
she started voting for George w Bush or
last,
uh,
two,
two election cycles.
So it's really ironic that it's not
messaging.
It's the fact that the country and the
country in general has gone to the left
and the Democrats to the,
to a greater degree than Republicans
have gone to the left.
The country has changed in part,
in my opinion,
because of immigration,
including illegal immigration.
People who are coming to the country
illegally from third world countries
like Mexico.
They don't know what I'm talking about
when I talk about limited government.
They believe healthcare is a right.
They're taught that in Mexico,
they're taught that other places and
they come here in America and they pull
that lever for the Democratic Party,
which is why,
in my opinion,
the left wants borders to be poorest
because it changes the country,
changed the electorate,
it changes the demographics and all
that.
The Democratic Party has not won the
white vote since 1964.
The more white people there are in the
country,
the worst Democrats do.
The more left wing,
the more people of color there are in
the country,
the best the left does.
And so what incentive is there for them
to,
to police the borders?
What incentive is there for them to shut
down on sanctuary cities,
uh,
to,
to stop catch and release?
There isn't,
in my opinion,
there's been a very subtle and very
diabolical changing or the mentality of
this country by left wing people so that
a state like California could never vote
for Ronald Reagan as they did in the
past,
could never vote for Richard Nixon as
they did in the past.
You have New York and California just
write them off and there's 10 or 12
states now that we fight over.
Everything else has now written off.
It's ridiculous.
So at the top of the show,
when I was laying out some of the
principles that we're talking about
here,
I saw classical liberalism falling into
the conservative category,
as you just said.
And it's funny because while I consider
myself a classical liberal and we can
lay out every liberal principle there is
that I would defend.
Uh,
it's,
it's scary to me because the.
Because we get so caught up in words
that,
you know,
oh,
I don't want to be considered a
conservative because I'm a liberal.
It's a scary proposition,
right?
Well,
again,
it's,
it's about limited government personal
responsibility as far as I'm concerned.
What you've told me is that you are
really a,
somebody on my camp far more so than
somebody on Bernie Sanders camp.
Well,
I'm liberal in that I'm for gay marriage
and I don't mind if you smoke weed in
your bedroom as a general rule.
I do like lower taxes,
but I think we could have a progressive
tax at some level,
so we probably disagree a little bit
there.
I do think you should if you keep making
more and more and especially as you're
getting into the dozens of millions and
hundreds of millions.
Yeah,
we could have a progressive tax that
would attack the taxes people more.
I'm not necessarily for the 90 percent
tax that,
that Bernie wants.
Uh,
so I,
you know,
some of the economics.
I wonder,
let me ask you,
why is it that nobody gave Dick Cheney
love?
Because Cheney had a more progressive
position on same sex marriage than Obama
did when Obama was still.
But we're changing,
evolving.
Cheney Cheney didn't have it until he
was out of office.
So that's,
uh,
you know,
it's a little disingenuous.
What he did,
he still years before Obama said he was
in favor of gay marriage,
said,
I'm in favor of allowing states to
determine this.
He said that years before that,
while he was in office,
though,
I don't think that was while he was all
I know was years before Obama because
Obama became president 2008.
He's not only said that he was in favor
of traditional marriage.
He said God was in the mix.
All of a sudden years later,
God is no longer mix four years ago.
Then God got out of the mix.
But anyway,
the point is that Dick Cheney said that
he supported same sex marriage on a
state by state basis.
Well before the left,
did well before Obama did well before
Hillary did gotten olaf.
So isn't actually well that I think
would just go to.
Because politicians are pandering.
I mean that.
I don't know that that makes Obama
anymore of a liar than any other
politician make.
As much as they will just talk.
I'm telling you,
I'm paying,
I'm talking about.
I get you.
I'm talking about why somebody didn't
give it.
Give it a couple of attaboys on that.
I know that people on the left hate him,
called him a neocon and believe he was
whispering and George w Bush's ear and
got Bush to do all sorts of bad things,
but I would've,
I would've thought on this issue since
the left considered such,
such an important issue.
I don't,
by the way,
that they would not have given it a
little bit of bit.
What do you mean you don't consider same
sex marriage to be that big of a deal?
To me it's a give people equality and
then let's not think about it anymore.
That would.
Fair enough.
I'm just saying I,
I think the number one issue in this
country is self defense.
Uh,
and,
and the number one domestic policy issue
that,
as I mentioned,
is the destruction of the family.
These other things,
a same sex marriage,
war on drugs,
a global warming.
I considered to be further down the
list.
So the war on drugs,
you're,
you're actually for legalizing drugs,
right?
I'm,
I'm for the government getting out of it
both federally and at the state level.
Yeah.
And that would be an interestingly,
this may be a little boring for your,
for your viewers,
but,
but um,
uh,
in the,
in the earlier in the 20th century,
we had the war against alcohol.
The constitution was amended,
the fight,
the war against alcohol,
and then it was amended again when we
decided it didn't work.
We've had,
since Richard Nixon,
this war on drugs,
the constitution was never amended for
that.
And I don't understand why people don't
make the argument that it is illegal
what the federal government is doing
because in order to get rid of alcohol,
Congress knew that they had to change
the constitution,
which they did.
There's no power in article one,
section eight that gives the federal
government the authority to wage a war
on alcohol or a war on,
on,
on drugs.
But to do the one on alcohol,
they changed the constitution and then
rechanged it.
But they never did that for the war on
drugs.
Yeah.
So how much of that do you think goes to
why the black family has been affected?
I mean,
when you think about the amount of black
people,
black men especially,
and minorities in general that are in
jail,
we now have pro for profit jails and a
huge percentage of these people are in
jail because of drug offenses.
Well,
not that many about 12 to 15 percent,
but,
but whatever.
That seems pretty significant,
whatever the percentage is,
I think the war on drugs should be
rethought and we should deal with it as
a health problem and not a criminal
justice problem,
but the reason for the large number of
black behind bars goes back to what I
said earlier about the breakdown of the
black family,
uh,
and not being taught the right kinds of
values.
Uh,
and that has all sorts of other social
consequences including,
uh,
a greater propensity to commit crime.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
let's back up for a second because you
quickly say something about Hollywood
and I know I follow you on twitter and
you rail against Hollywood.
All I do.
Basically your argument is that it's
like kicking a puppy though.
It's become,
and I can tell you not.
It's not that difficult.
Right.
So,
so just the other night,
you know,
you were,
you were tweeting a little bit about the
Golden Globes and the targets that your
base was taking.
Last night I saw you,
uh,
on CNN,
Don Lemon,
who I had on last week was on the show
last week.
He was talking about Tavis Smiley and
you're not a fan of travis.
I've known him a long time.
He's a,
he,
he doesn't preach what he practices,
what he is,
a hardworking guy who came from Indiana
with a big poor family and has done
quite well with his life.
And instead of telling people,
bust your butt,
do what I did.
Work hard,
stay focused.
It's demands out to get you a social
injustice.
Racism,
racism everywhere.
It's nonsense.
Hollywood is an easy target because
these guys,
the Golden Globes,
they've got these fine clothing
designer,
a clothing and designed designer Tux
and,
and their jewelry.
They're all anti second amendment,
but they're all protected by armed
security guard.
Uh,
and um,
how many of them,
uh,
applied into a Prius to get to and from
the,
uh,
the ceremony.
I mean,
you're saying very few.
I think very,
very few.
They in big gas.
Guzzling not a large number of limos.
Yeah.
And notice it.
Notice there were several bill cosby
jokes,
I think three or four bill cosby rape
jokes.
Not One Bill Clinton rape joke.
Poor quality.
Yeah.
Uh,
do you think,
I mean,
I'm a firm believer that a lot of them
actually privately are supporting
Republicans or at least their voting
Republican.
There is this idea that,
okay,
we're going to go on this.
You can't say you can't say it out loud.
Name One,
a list.
Young actor or actress who's an out of
the closet Republican.
Just one young,
20,
30 eastern.
You can do it once.
Your Clint Eastwood,
once your Kelsey grammer boy,
does it count as you,
right?
No,
no,
but,
but somebody in his twenties,
thirties,
Jennifer Lawrence,
uh,
age star,
they want this guy to be somebody.
They can't be 100 percent a left wing,
but they will not say so because they
know they won't get parts and you would
say that's not necessarily because they
believe those things as much as just the
structures in place.
It's bigotry in Hollywood that the open
minded,
empathetic people,
they're fine as long as you don't say
something that pisses them off.
Yeah.
And,
and,
uh,
you say that you're gonna support,
Donald Trump,
you won't work if you're 20 or 30 years
old.
You won't work.
You're going to lose jobs.
Yeah.
So let's talk a little bit about your
thoughts and think and think about that.
These are,
these are the people who are in charge
of 80 percent of what we see on TV and
on and in movies.
And if you come out and you're 20 or 30
years old and you're a rising star and
you say,
you know what?
Listen to Larry elder's show the other
day.
I think,
um,
I'm going to vote Republican.
Finished,
done,
done now.
Now,
what kind of power is that to influence
the minds of young people to shape this
country culturally,
it is massive.
There was a book called Primetime
propaganda by a young man named Ben
Shapiro.
We're getting them on the show and uh,
and because he looks so young and looks
liberal,
whatever that means,
he was able to get on the record all
these Hollywood producers,
people that did golden girls,
people that did cops and got them on the
record saying,
I would never hire a conservative.
A conservative in this town will be
screwed.
A conservative in this town cannot make
it.
I intentionally put leftwing messages in
my fair.
I try to influence culture this way,
has them all saying this and has an on
tape.
And the book came out and it didn't make
any difference.
They didn't say,
I'm sorry,
I didn't say we ought to rethink our
assumptions.
He interviewed Fred Silverman,
who at one time as the head of ABC,
CBS,
NBC has Fred Silverman on the record
saying a conservative cannot make it in
this town.
Now,
if Hollywood has a great impact on how
we think on our culture and you have
this Gestapo essentially shutting out
people who are conservative,
what does that say?
It's scary to frightening to me.
Yeah.
Well,
messaging messaging is everything,
which actually brings this back to what
you said about trump before,
which I think is sort of fascinating
that he's polling better with the black
community is because he has this sense
of swagger,
which I think you could probably relate
directly back to,
you know,
rap music and stuff like that.
These guys aren't,
they're not ashamed of their success and
that.
So in a weird way,
trump is sort of doing the exact same
the exact thing that you want,
uh,
to happen.
I agree,
but I think it was another big reason
that trump is scoring with white people.
Uh,
one of the most underpolled things in
this country is how black people are
pissed off about illegal immigration.
When I was younger,
there was a movie that came out of the
seventies called carwash,
or Richard Pryor was in it,
um,
and George or George Carlin was in it.
Yeah.
And it was about a day in the life of
this carwash in south central,
not too far from where I grew up.
Virtually all the employees were black.
I defy you to go to a car wash and south
central now and see any,
any employee who's black illegal
immigrants that come over and taking
over this business,
uh,
and black people see it and they,
and they realize it and they are angry
about it.
Uh,
and the Democratic Party,
however,
because of what I said earlier about
trying to shift the electorate to the
left,
uh,
has,
in my opinion,
thrown blacks under the bus on this
issue.
And a lot of blacks who are aware of it
or not happy about it.
And Donald Trump's position on
immigration,
uh,
resonated with a lot of black people.
The other thing about,
about Donald trump that I think in
general,
not just black people,
uh,
is appealing to me anyway.
And I'm not quite sure why some of my
fellow Republicans are so adamantly
opposed to Donald Trump.
This guy,
Dave can self fund.
He doesn't need your money.
Uh,
Donald Trump was at a group called the
Republican Jewish coalition and he was
asked a question about does he feel that
a Jerusalem should be the undivided
capital of Israel?
His answers not important.
He said something like,
uh,
I'm not sure I haven't thought it
through.
And he got booed and Donald trump looked
up and he said,
I don't need your money now.
There's a guy named Nelson Sheldon
Adelson in Las Vegas.
He's a multibillionaire last election
cycle.
He gave Newt Gingrich 10 million a lot
of money and a lot of people feel that,
but for that,
Newt Gingrich is a tackle and Mitt
Romney and all the footage that he gave
Democrats to use and the general
election,
Romney might have one.
That's not the point.
The point is he is a king maker.
Um,
and right now he is trying to decide
whether he wants to give money to a Ted
Cruz or Marco Rubio.
He has Los Vegas business interests.
I'm not mad at him for doing something
to pursue his interests.
But the point is,
he expected his phone call to return to
be returned.
Donald trump can say,
screw you to all these people,
the people that get subsidized for milk,
the people that get subsidies for sugar,
the people that get subsidies for this
ridiculous product known as ethanol,
uh,
the,
the unions that keep Amtrak running.
Donald trump does not need their money.
He does not have to take their phone
call.
So what's guy can really do what should
be done for the American people,
which is to get all the crony capitalism
and all these so called special
interests out of our government and get
it down to the site.
That oughta be Boeing gets money from
the government.
Google gets money from the government.
Dutch royal gets money from the
government.
This is corporate welfare.
And the reason that happens is because
they give contribution to the
politicians who in turn then do their
bidding.
Donald trump does not need their money.
He is in a position to downsize the
government in a way unlike any other
politician
I've ever seen.
Yeah.
So there's the.
I mean,
there's a lot of irony there.
You've,
what you're really talking about is
that's truly systemic political
problems.
Tell me about it,
the money politics study,
so that's,
and that's.
That should unite everybody across the
board about how messed up our system
should.
I mean,
right now a la is going to get to team
two football teams,
probably Oakland and San Diego and St
Louis are all vying to come out here.
By the way,
all three of them used to play here.
Rams used to play here,
open up to play here,
and the first a La chargers,
one of the AFL teams started here and
they moved to San Diego.
Now they don't want to come back.
Why?
Because their respective cities won't
give them hundreds of billions of
dollars in tax subsidies.
Why should a multibillionaire get
millions of dollars from taxpayers who
then in turn have to pay all this to go
to the game and watch multimillionaire
ballplayers be?
Well,
that's like sitting corporate welfare,
that's molesting city field where the
mets play in New York,
you know that it was funded by,
partly by taxpayer money,
but meanwhile the government's bailing
out Citibank who has their name on the
whole thing is reduced.
So the trump thing,
real quick,
one of the things is in the first
debate,
the first republican debate about three
months ago now,
I thought the,
the unmasking that he did was actually
kind of amazing,
even though I disagree with him on
pretty much everything,
but you know,
when they asked him about going to
Hillary's a daughter's wedding,
right?
Uh,
he goes to Chelsea's wedding and he was
like,
yeah,
I give them money.
Show up the wedding.
Yeah.
I give money to everybody.
I'm a business guy.
I got it.
I got to do what I gotta do.
So in a weird way,
even if you don't like.
So for my,
for my liberal friends and my friends
had left,
even if you hate the messaging and you
know,
all the Muslim stuff and all that,
even if you hate all that,
the unmasking of the system.
And that's why I've also talked about
how Bernie and trump have a lot in
common because the core of what they're
doing is the biggest threat to the
system.
Right,
right.
Bernie and trump have a lot in common in
the sense that the establishment is
scared to death of both of them.
Uh,
but,
uh,
Bernie will make things worse.
Taking over large corporations will make
things worse.
Raising taxes on job creators will make
things worse with Donald trump wants to
do.
I will make things better.
All right.
Well,
uh,
I barely got to any of the questions I
have here,
which is a testament to you,
so I'm glad we've got to sit down.
So let me end this thing and a little
bit of the future where you think this
country is going in the next year.
Do you.
So I sent.
Are you supporting trump?
I haven't taken a position on anybody
yet,
so I will support whoever the nominee is
over Hillary Clinton or Bernie Sanders.
Certainly,
yeah.
Do you view he'll,
hillary and Bernie both sort of as
equally,
uh,
equally equally as equally bad?
I mean,
when you've,
when you've asked Hillary to give the
difference,
as Chris Matthews recently did,
between a Democrat and a socialist,
she couldn't do it.
Debbie Wasserman Schultz,
the chairwoman of the DNC,
was asked the same question,
she couldn't do it,
uh,
and Hillary has gone further to the left
because she's threatened by Bernie
Sanders.
She's now come out by talking about a
surcharge tax on,
on,
on millionaire.
She didn't do that before and she's also
coming out on the left now on gun.
She didn't want to do that before.
So Bernie's pushed her to the left.
So as far as I'm concerned,
their positions are pretty much
indistinguishable.
Yeah.
And again,
this may go to show why the system is
just broken because both sides in the
primary process have to stake out these
positions that they know that they're
not going to govern by.
Richard Nixon used to say when you want
to win a presidency and the primary,
you run to the right and then when you
run into the general election,
you run to the center.
That's kind of how it works.
And the primary season you have to run
to your base and then kind of run to the
standard different.
Trying to get independence.
That's just how it works.
Yeah.
All right,
well listen,
I've thoroughly enjoyed talking to you.
I didn't expect we were going to agree
on everything.
We didn't.
That's fine.
Maybe I learned a little something here.
Maybe you learned a little bit.
Maybe you learned a little something
going on.
So I see a glimmer in your eye.
So if you move a little bit towards the
center.
Well I consider my has a classical
liberal.
I don't,
I don't consider myself off the deep end
left and maybe I just,
I think in general a lot of people on
the left are starting to realize how do
you feel about vouchers?
Uh,
I think we should have vouchers.
I think you should have access to God.
How do you feel about affirmative
action?
How do you feel about giving a black
person or a brown person?
Additional points just because they're
black and brown over some equally
qualified white person.
Are you happy with that?
Unhappy.
Don't care.
Oh Man.
Now I'm being interviewed.
All right.
So yeah,
I would say that I think at some time,
at some point in America there was a
reason that it really did make sense
because because some of the more
systemic stuff still exists today and
today it probably doesn't make as much
sense anymore.
I think you would agree with me on that
because that's pretty much what you just
don't think it ever made anything,
but that's exactly why I want to have
these conversations and why especially I
think that that liberals and
Libertarians should realize that we're
sort of in the center together and that
there's a way to,
there's a way to work together.
So that's exactly why I wanted to do
that.
Fair enough.
So,
all right,
so I thank my guest,
Larry Elder.
Uh,
you can check out clips of the Larry
elder's show and more are Larry's
work@Larryelder.com.